so comedian dave chappelle facing some
backlash once again for including jokes
about transgender people the blow back
to dave chappelle dave chappelle is
under fire you see people trying to
cancel dave chappelle show and they go
if i said any of these things at my job
they'd fire me immediately well dave
doesn't work at 3m
[Music]
the reality is like 90 of the country
still likes comedy the way it's been for
the last 50 years to me like true
equality is everybody and
you're making fun of everybody equally
when you start worrying about what the
world is going to think uh of what your
your art is your art's going to be very
very terrible i live in brooklyn new
york i work at netflix in the city i
walked out of the office and i just kept
on
walking i don't think america has gotten
too sensitive
we've just inflamed the very small
minority of people who are sensitive
and given them super powers
so powerful that 150
online protesters can get dave chappelle
perhaps one of the most famous comedians
of all time
removed from his show i actually don't
think america is too sensitive i think
people need to laugh people need to
laugh now more than ever i'm going to
try to take everything away from you and
i don't care what i find out could be
today tomorrow 15 20 years from now if i
find out you're
finished
who who's that
that's the people that want to censor
comedy or cancel comedians who are
you know being edgy taking risks pushing
the envelope i think they're a very very
organized vocal minority it's never
people who would ever even
have come to your standup show they're
not even your fans it's just they're not
even people that would really like
comedy in general you can't protect a
certain
group of people
um
they'll actually end up feeling excluded
and isolated you know i think comedy is
is like the most inclusive thing you
know when you hang out with your friends
what do you do you all make fun of each
other so
uh
you can't slowly start cutting out
topics and people that you can't joke
about but that's what they're doing on
netflix and that's why
the numbers are dwindling there really
is a clamoring uh and i think a
resurgence of audiences that just don't
want politically correct comedy anymore
they want things that are raw and
offensive and edgy and and i think we're
right on the cusp of this real
renaissance of comedy of uh guys that
are willing to push the envelope with
you know with comedy being that
prevalent and popular it seems like
everyone has an opinion on it and
especially not just what is in good
taste but how it should be done and who
should get to do it
[Applause]
so many people will say oh i love comedy
you could say whatever you want you
can't offend me and that person who says
that is always the first person to get
up and walk out of the show because
inevitably everyone has some line that
some sacred cow that they believe is not
okay to make fun of a lot of americans
that want to suppress the freedom of
comedy for the same reasons they want to
suppress a lot of these other freedom of
freedoms that are just things that they
disagree with
people have become accustomed to like
well i want it off my screen so i want
to make it so this person never works
again
whereas before it's like if you didn't
like a comedian you just wouldn't see
them now it's like oh i don't like this
comedian and i and i don't agree with
them with things they say or joke about
and i don't not only do i not want to
see them but i want to make sure nobody
else can see them it's ultimately the
most selfish thing you can do it's like
you're saying
my wants my likes my dislikes need that
has to be the gold standard so much of
what people ask you to defend both on
the internet and and in comedy and in
your artistic stuff
is they want you to defend what their
interpretation of it was am i canceled
or
not too often too much credit is given
to the way people
interpret what you're saying or what
you're doing as a comedian rather than
what your real intentions are and the
more credibility we lend that with
responding the worse this problem is
going to get so when you see venues like
first avenue cave to the mob that's
what's dangerous about it is because
that basically tells all those
transgender people that what they think
dave chappelle's saying about them is
true and that's not the case at all i i
used to kind of play it safe i would do
a lot of impressions you know i'd
frankly do a lot of donald trump and i'd
make fun of donald trump for four years
and then i made fun of biden and they're
like oh you're far right i'm like no
he's in power i make fun of who's in
power
uh so i've been
terrified to
kind of step outside of that that
you know woke bubble i don't have a
political party and but people will tell
me all the time like man your comedy has
gone so right-wing
but the fact is the left has gone so far
that now anything sort of nuanced in the
middle
um
uh non-censored is considered far right
now if you attack anthony dr anthony
fauci you are also attacking science and
equality through comedy is everyone gets
made fun of
because like
true equality is like you're not so
special that we're gonna pretend you're
not even here so that's what's a real
concerning thing is that we have almost
this religious crusade now with the
political sides over who is right and
who is wrong and people now have this
idea that if i believe you're wrong and
people agree with me then there is no
limit to to which freedoms i'm willing
to take away from you and that's just
not in the spirit of america
freedom now is extreme uh having an
american flag is extreme comedy's about
bringing joy to people you know and and
even when that outrages people in some
way it's triggering those sensory
receptors for them that it ultimately
gives them some pleasure even if they're
opposing what you're saying i think the
outrage is more about the fact that we
believe we're allowed to live like that
rather than outrage about what we're
actually saying it just feels so
counterintuitive to like why any of us
do comedy in the first place if you're
gonna start editing it guys gotta
remember i'm not saying it to be mean
i'm saying it because it's funny
comedians just need to stop buying into
all the noise and they need to just
start
telling jokes how they want
you're never going to develop as an
artist unless you
cross the line i really try to keep the
artist mindset about comedy and just if
it genuinely makes me laugh whether
people think it's appropriate or not i
try to build from that place
and i will either make fans or not based
on the kind of content i do but i'd
rather take the the the tortoises race
to the finish of making the kind of fans
i want than just doing what's easy to
appease people
you can get kind of caught up in the in
the really loud kind of woke you can't
say anything we're triggered just um
this is violent
but if you look over on this side uh
people still still want to hear jokes um
and and hear comedians take risks so
it's a lot more painful at first but
once you get through that uh there's a
light at the end
black people in the front what's going
on
you trying to get me canceled you're not
gonna like find success and find your
people by kind of like playing it safe
and that's what it's about it's like
it's an art form you have to take risks
the minute you start doing it for other
people uh it stops being funny and it
stops being true to you
you